well we are teaming up with digital
media company refinery29 this week for a
series called my vote we're exploring
the impact of millennial women on the
upcoming midterm elections Alex Wagner
spoke with a group of millennial women
voters from Pennsylvania at Frankfurt
Hall in Philadelphia Alex is here with
that morning guys our panel included
three Republicans Trump supporter
Brittney Christensen Jessica Barnett who
did not vote for President Trump and
identifies more as an independent and
Colette Forrester who voted for the
first time in 2016 because she wanted to
see mr. Trump elected three Democrats on
the panel were Lauren Hughes who voted
for Hillary Clinton Jamie a mo a
lifelong independent who registered as a
Democrat in 2016 and voted for Clinton
and Melissa Alam who first supported
Bernie Sanders but Bo voted for Hillary
Clinton in the general election
he's women range in age from 26 to 34
they all say they plan to vote in
November's midterms do you think
Millennials are as polarized as the rest
of the country yeah I think we
definitely are I think when I personally
find out someone voted for Trump I just
changed my opinion of them right away I
actually don't have any Republican
friends that I know of so there's a lot
of people that won't speak up because
when they're online or they you know
post their opinion on social media they
are immediately attacked they're called
a bigot a racist a xenophobe all of
those things and those are the worst
things you can be called especially when
you are not one yeah so for me I became
a Republican when I was 12 years old and
started early yes it wasn't until Trump
that I've had friends um not be friends
with me anymore I've had numerous
numerous people come to me privately and
they told me that they supported Trump
but if I outed them in public
they would flat out deny it that they're
literally afraid to speak their minds
and they can't believe that I speak my
mind immigration is very much in the
news who here is in favor of a wall sort
of a half wall why walls work you might
not like the wall but walls work it will
cost money
yeah it'll save money by
not having the illegals and drugs
pouring over the border and having to
deal with the repercussions here we do
one immigrants we want people come to
our nation yeah we're completely
supportive and when you look at the
lottery system I mean why are we giving
away US citizenship over a lottery we
should be doing it merit-based and
picking the best is right once if that's
to the end brightest to come in you
don't want the leftovers yeah let me get
your thoughts on some of this I know
that Melissa your parents are immigrants
I never saw it as a big deal I thought
that this was a country where people
would come to you know have a better
life my parents came from Bangladesh in
the 80s and I feel like we deserve to be
here I thought this was the land of
opportunity so to build a wall against
other human beings is just not right to
me what do you think should be done
though there's there are calls on the
Democratic side to abolish ice mm-hmm I
think we've seen enough from these camps
that they're having the separation of
families I just I'm so appalled at
what's happening I'm another I I don't
believe that the children should be
separated from their parents but what
they're doing is you know they would
come in here with their child in that
way we catch your release and now we can
actually hold them what do you think of
the family separations policy I'm not
very supportive of it because I don't
think it actually achieves the goal of
promoting legal immigration I just think
it's punitive it distracts from the
actual calls for true reform let's talk
about guns who here owns a gun what do
you think about efforts to promote gun
safety reform I'm an attorney and I
practice in mental health law as well
and I do believe there needs to be some
safeguards in place for gun ownership I
think you need to dig a little bit
deeper whether it's to someone's mental
health history I just think there needs
to be a process involved ed delves into
people's backgrounds a little further
than just what's on the surface of a
conviction Colette I saw you know yeah I
agree with her I think that there should
be maybe a mental health check something
like that
I believe that people should be able to
protect themselves their families in
their homes but you don't need a
semi-automatic weapon to protect
yourself maybe she though should be
banned I mean the Second Amendment was
put in place because of protecting the
citizens from a tyrannical government so
if the government has these guns we
should have the guns
jaimé guns I mean guys this is my issue
want you want the machine guns go for it
but please lock them up and please keep
the ammunition separate this goes back
many times in my life I was 15 years old
I was a ninth grader , in high school
and I can tell you that it doesn't
matter what color the criminal is and
what kind of weapon were worried about
when that gun is five feet away from you
and people that you know are being
killed you kind of stop and you think
well hey maybe we've gone a little too
far with this maybe there is something
we can do but to say that we can't do
anything to address anything about the
guns is it's giving up it's not going to
help anybody it's not going to protect
any will anyone really for me it's all
about can I relate to that person you
know gun violence to me is you know what
I see on TV but I have sitting next to
someone that has been a victim I can
look at it another you know another way
as a gun-toting person it's not okay
when someone like her
you know another human being has been
through a situation like oh yeah it
sounds like everybody wants us to see
each other's humanity and all of this
right I think that's what's going to
bring us back together as a country it
was a really emotional conversation and
you saw there's some common ground on
issues of gun safety reform and to some
degree even marriage equality but on
issues like immigration and health care
very steep divides and the fact that
these groups of women are getting their
basic facts and information from
radically different sources makes
finding that common ground a lot harder
and what was it like when the taping was
over did they run for the hills or did
they continue to talk to each other it
was interesting we started out in one
place things got really fraught in the
middle
you saw at the end you know there is
when you sit in a room with people and
talk to them you recognize you know
we're all humans we're all part of this
project to call them that called America
and and finding our basic humanity is
gonna be the thing that stitches this
country back together so hard to hate up
close I say that all dr. Brown
yeah who can get in the same room and
talk good stuff happened colette brought
cookies and those are also a thing that
brings people together bring some carbs
yeah but yeah it was very eye-opening
using the term leftovers though it was a
bit jarring I do have to say and shots
of immigration the rhetoric around
immigration is really been ratcheted up
Alex thank you thank you guys